Material Design Lite, or MDL,
gives designers and developers
a way to add a material look
and feel to their websites
based on Google's
design guidelines.
But what is MDL, and
what makes it lite?
I'm Mustafa Kurtuldu,
Design Advocate at Google.
And in this video, I'll give
an overview of the material
design guidelines, the
intentions behind MDL,
and the resources we have
to help build and develop
your own MDL website.
Material design
guidelines were born out
of a need to create a
consistent user experience
across multiple platforms.
Consistency is really
important, as people
tend to jump from
one device to another
throughout their working day.
For example, while
traveling in the morning,
they may use a mobile device.
At school or work, they'll be
on their desktop or laptop.
And in the evening, they
may switch to a tablet.
This continuous device switching
means applications and websites
need to transfer
these experiences
across different boundaries.
For this, we must create a
continuous, a ubiquitous user
experience.
And this is where
material design can help.
To understand this
further, let's take a look
at the building blocks of
Google's design language.
Material design is broken down
into three core principles--
material as a metaphor;
meaningful motion; and bold,
graphic, and intentional.
These principles help
define the relationship
between the user
and the UI, which
is also called affordance.
Good affordance can
be the difference
between a user
naturally knowing how
to perform an action
in your application
or getting frustrated
and confused.
The first principle,
material as a metaphor,
introduces the idea that every
element in an application
is made of a flexible and
tangible piece of material,
similar to paper.
Each piece of material
can be any shape, size,
has a thickness,
occupies its own depth,
and can be elevated above
other pieces of material
to demonstrate its
importance simply
by casting a realistic shadow.
By using shadows and
other familiar things
from our everyday experiences
in the real world,
we can naturally
relate to material.
And this helps us quickly
understand the affordances
in our application.
The second principle
of material design
is meaningful motion, which
describes how bits of material
move and relate to a
person's click or touch.
Every transition must appear
natural and help guide a person
to perform a specific
task and not simply
be decorative distractions.
Material can shrink,
grow, rotate,
or move across any axis
so long as it does so
in a meaningful context.
The third principle
of material design
is bold, graphic,
and intentional.
This principle references
the classic standards
from print design
and will determine
how material looks by using
typography, grids, space,
scale, color, and imagery.
Together, all of these
principles and design
considerations is what
we call material design.
The material design principles
can be applied to any platform,
though the guidelines
are extremely rich,
and this can be a
bit overwhelming.
This is where Material
Design Lite can help.
The reason why we
add the word "lite"
is because we avoid
implementing the full animation
support for some of
the motion transitions.
This means you can ship a
[? fast ?] [? static ?] site
with a material
design look and feel.
To make MDL available
to all developers,
the project is open-source.
So whether you have a
content-heavy website
or a simple, static
website, you can use MDL.
To use MDL, simply link
to the CSS file on our CDN
and add the relevant
CSS classes and HTML
markup depending on the MDL
components you may wish to use.
For example, we have
a layout component
that is fully responsive and
allows you to design and build
custom page layouts.
We also have simple,
small UI components,
like the progress bar, for
indicating loading and progress
states.
Each component has a basic usage
with a number of CSS classes
you can add to the HTML in
order to change the default
behavior or styles.
You can find out more
about MDL components
and how they are implemented
on our website, getmdl.io.
For those of you who
want to create a custom
theme for your website,
we have a color wheel
that lets you change the
default, primary, and accent
colors of our UI elements.
We also have pre-built
templates at our website
that you can use as a
source of inspiration,
as well as a showcase
section on our website that
displays existing sites
currently using MDL,
such as Google Wallet,
Contributor, and Web Starter
Kit.
Again, all of these can be
seen on our website, getmdl.io.
So that's material design
and Material Design Lite.
And now that you have an
understanding of how MDL works,
you can craft the
perfect website
to suit yours and
your users' needs.
For more information about
MDL or material design,
you can check out these links.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]